i have a friend who is a legitimate
tour the world rock star right front man
for a band
right like a groupie [ __ ] dude right
like that's just
like he has had that life
and the stories he tells are
crazy all right
when i was young and i was famous
and i can remember now the occasional
person kind of like really sort of
throwing themselves at me
i never was receptive to that because i
felt like
that person doesn't see me that person
sees the thing from tv in the movies and
i'm tired of being that thing
i don't want to be that thing i'm that
thing in my house i'm that thing wow you
felt this young age yeah i was super
aware of it i was super aware i was
aware of it when we were doing you were
uncomfortable extremely uncomfortable
and i didn't like it and i was like you
know what
i i understand now you know as an i've
been married for 25 years
and and it's great i'm like and like my
wife is my favorite person in the world
and and we were talking the other day
about how when we were younger like we
just weren't people who were kind of
like
i don't know sexually adventurous or
like you know fooling around with tons
of different people and stuff like that
and it turned out that
we both came at that from a place of
like i just want someone to see me
right like if you could see me instead
of your idea of what you want me to be
this would be really great yeah let's
fool around it'll be fun right yeah but
like
i don't want to be your thing
and that was how i felt for
so much
of of my entire childhood so when
when that was all i felt like and i felt
like the only way
i
mattered in my home i knew i didn't
matter to my dad
but i thought really was it was it with
the what did he what did he say to you
what actions would he have that made you
feel like that